yo so another you know when we watch the
battle chance everybody who watched the
vs. battle which you and Manny fresh the
dr. Dre records I think are kind of like
had to be like one of like the turning
crowning moments of your career like
talk about like obviously being a part
of chronic 2001 which was very very
interesting time in hip hop cuz I
remember that album being teased for so
long and I remember death row
cock-blocking and putting out an album
called allicin yeah and we had to make
it chronic mm right cuz it came out and
like I remember I was like tooth like
that didn't make sense but I remember
that weird-ass death row album it had
like a cigar on yeah had the cigar on
the cover and then the guy who sounded
just like Snoop Dogg there was a guy on
that album that was like a snoop
impersonator I swear to God
sure was petty but nonetheless like that
album was it's one of the top 10
greatest hip hop albums of all time
can you talk about like how did that
initial connection happen with Dre I
think you've spoken a lot about like the
process of making those records but like
you getting into the fold with Dre
becoming a part of that team that worked
on that project okay so there was
obviously the moment where I left the
roots and I was trying to make a career
for myself what year did you officially
like breakaway in 95 okay yeah I left
the group I actually ended up in 97
getting a visit from them when I was in
the middle of working on a song but
that's all other story and I gave them
more records but at this point I'm
trying to make a life for myself as a
producer and you know I was struggling
so the roots had a I'm hoping mic women
in music series that they used to do
every Sunday at the wetlands okay in New
York and every Sunday for a year I would
do this I was part of the house band was
me Questlove you know cup
other cats and then like crazy I mean
all everybody was there common was
always there you know Erykah Badu was
there he's got me it was a movie it went
on every Sunday so finally after a year
of doing that they did one in California
at the martini lounge okay so I see this
girl when I go out to the martini lounge
my first time ever in in California I've
never been to Cali and this girl from
Philly comes up to me that I knew a
rapper that I worked with whatever and
it was Eve trying to Eve and Eve was
like yo I got I got a I got a record
deal with dr. Dre this is prior to her
going to reference before we like really
knew Eve yes she was like me before she
wasn't like upstream to downstream she
was side streamed I guess you know Dre
was so busy with em and you know yeah
Dre had that weird era where he put out
that aftermath album with the bomb on
the cover and it was like more like a
compilation album yeah this was ever
after that yeah okay okay okay so yeah
we've been there done that yeah yeah
that record yeah so so um I'm like out
there like I'm literally at this moment
in my life probably two months behind in
my rent and like struggling whatever and
she's like come me dr. Dre probably like
98 99 let's find a 99
okay 19 is getting a 99 well yeah maybe
it wasn't 98 he wasn't idea um at any
rate she says come me talk to Trey and
you know playing some music I was like I
don't have any music with me so we'll
come play the piano for him because I
didn't have any that tapes CDs and um I
played I sat in the lobby and waited for
a few hours and you know he's like I
hear you hot on them keys
so I played some [ __ ] he was like that
he was like don't go anywhere
got a hotel room key and [ __ ] stack
of money like everything it's like [ __ ]
with us we were making this album and uh
he's just like the vibe it like this
different like style I guess that he was
used to hearing
you know California musicians that he
would bring in different keyboard
players yeah and it was something
completely different
East Coast but still like Universal
about it and he was [ __ ] with it so he
put me on the team Bros and it was honor
I learned everything there it's where I
learned to really understand music
production and how long was that era of
your career where you were in there
learning like woods right yeah like how
long did that last like four or five
years
so you're just soaking up like
everything like because he's so
meticulous I hear he's crazy about Sean
Anders like you said you hated hearing
the gyro song in the club because you
could tell the difference is probably
probably got that for being around Jess
a little short um it's insane to think
like I feel like it's like still d-r-e
like low-key like the fact that you're a
kid from Philly and kind of shaped like
West Coast Sonics for like the next like
eight or nine years cuz if you go and
like listen to like Games documentary
like I just feel like those keys aren't
there west coast now like it's like you
know what I'm saying like there's
records that you hear that are like we
kind of you know I can't take credit for
like I mean Dre's productions obviously
yeah yeah like I brought to the table I
slowly like the chronic mm I brought a
certain it was more I mean was
production but it was like even more
like want to call it writing like we
were writing these things and this and
that and you know he was you know he
definitely had a vision for what he was
doing but I brought a new sound that was
different like then you know g-funk
exactly thing going on it was more
orchestral like pianos and you know
totally new did you because at the time
Dre had so many artists then I mean damn
I would have loved to have heard what a
rock came album what it sounded like
under aftermath we were around for some
of that did you I was gonna ask you did
you work on the unreleased Rakim album
yeah how was that how did I you know
that rock him come meet me in Miami one
time work with me now is this like
really doesn't fly
actually is this like peak like storage
like Miami time
yeah but ya know what I mean we I worked
with him with Dre mm-hmm like right in
LA and then I worked with him later and
there has to be like legend talked about
right like that the rock in music that
you heard while he was under aftermath
cuz we never got to hear any of it I
mean someone's [ __ ] was pretty dope I
can't front it was it was pure
unadulterated him he's just kind of
rapper that like once he opens his voice
you he's got a tone and a particular
style grabs your attention man DMX one
of those oh yeah shout to the belly
poster in the room legendary yeah no
that's I always like even like hit man
there was I just felt like there was so
many fire artists under after method
Devin the Dude did he sign after me
no I mean I'm just saying on that album
Devin's one of my favorites I rap a lot
rose so he he definitely did his thing
on facts and you know I I miss it so
much but I used to all the time after
you know being in that crew be able to
call my brother Nate Dogg four hooks
four songs and you just you knew you was
gonna get a hit you know you're like
goodnight goodnight you and you and
Nate's relationship very strong Stimpy's
yeah we were cool that's crazy because
I'd like what was the that he was gonna
wasn't he on a kiss record it you did we
did yeah he was but there was a record
that I really liked dub C and him the
streets Def Jam ya know heisman was the
name of that Alvia you know Dempsey one
of my favorite west coast rappers ever
doesn't get enough respect my favorite
of the three in West Side connection for
the record shot Ice Cube and Mack Tannen